The last time we had a block of two or
more consecutive sets on the same plane
was about three years ago with every set
since being a one-off set. Not only
this, but there hasn't been a multi-set
block in a brand new plane since Ixalan
block concluded more than eight years
ago. These facts stand in stark contrast
to earlier eras of magic, which for
decades had us venture to one plane a
year over the course of three sets,
often a brand new plane. To be clear,
this change was intentional. Its
communication was public and its reasons
for happening were on some level
understandable. Later sets in blocks
sold worse than earlier ones. Limited
environments were tricky to make
satisfying. And a set with lukewarm
reception getting followed up with an
immediate double and triple down to the
same setting was certainly not an ideal
outcome for developers or players, you
might reasonably say.
And yet, to lay my cards on the table
here, I do not like the new status quo
we find ourselves in. Having every set
be a new plane, particularly with five
or more sets per year, makes things feel
rushed. Makes it feel like there's no
time to breathe and to become immersed
in a particular world. And if I really
wanted to let nostalgia take the wheel
on this one, I could tell you that the
gradual pivot from three-set blocks to
purely one-off sets has been an
unambiguous tragedy, that we as magic
players are fallen and need to return to
the glory days of 2013, where magic sets
came in threes and where bold duels
could take place on a middle school
lunch table. I'd love to be able to
contribute yet another uncomplicated
piece of ammunition to the siege on the
decisions currently being made by
Hasbro, but in truth, the issue of
blocks is a bit more complicated than
that. I do think there is something
wrong with what we're currently doing,
where standard legal sets take us to six
or seven different planes every single
year, but three-set blocks don't really
represent a better vision of the game,
just one with a different set of
problems.
So here, I want to lay out my case for
what has gone wrong, both past and
present, and talk about an alternative
approach to the way we conceptualize
sets and their structuring. And I'll be
getting into a very specific missed
opportunity that occurred in 2024 that
provides a fascinating case study.
To start with, here's a very brief
timeline of blocks as a concept. The
first conventional three-set block was
Mirage block in 1996, and this would set
a trend of three-set blocks beginning in
October that would continue basically
uninterrupted for the following 18 years
until the release of Battle for
Zendikar. There were also yearly or
semi-yearly core sets over this span of
time, but aside from that and some
extras like Masters sets and un-sets,
the general idea was one block a year
and three sets per block. Then in 2015,
Magic: The Gathering switched to two-set
blocks, and this pattern would continue
until War of the Spark in 2019, which
was either a standalone set or the third
set of the third Ravnica block,
depending on how you count. From there,
sets were a mixture of one-offs like
Kaldheim and two-set blocks that
returned to a pre-existing plane, such
as Midnight Hunt. And the final two-set
return two-block ended about three years
ago with the release of March of the
Machine. Ever since, it's been all
one-offs with consecutive sets never
featuring the same setting.
And I guess I'll start my discussion of
blocks by saying that the current era of
blocks we're in does not feel very good,
and on a level pretty fundamental to the
way we experience the game. Obviously,
there are other factors contributing to
the way Magic feels in 2026, but the set
structure being all one-offs isn't
insignificant. The current progression
of things offers no time to stop and
breathe in a particular plane, no time
to be interested about what it has to
offer next, and no spare moments to stop
and reflect. Storylines are bouncing and
disconnected since we can never stop and
watch how a particular plane changes for
any length of time, only get a fleeting
snapshot of it before we're off to the
next place. Thought and effort is put
into how sets on different planes tie
into one another mechanically for
standard purposes, but we don't really
get to see iterations on a mechanical
theme like we did sometimes in the past.
Everything a plane has to offer needs to
be immediately present since there's
only one set worth of it. So, as you can
tell, I really don't think what we're
doing in the present is ideal. However,
that doesn't mean the way sets were
structured in the past was necessarily
better. And to explore that, we really
need to talk about three-set blocks.
This was the way Magic sets were
organized for years and years. And here
I want to hone in on the three blocks I
was fully around for: Return to Ravnica,
Theros, and Khans of Tarkir. RTR was
structured into the namesake set that
contained five of the guilds, Gatecrash,
which contained the other five, and
Dragon's Maze, which featured all 10
guilds. That final set also focused on
the maze, which was a sort of structure
built into the city and which would host
a race in which a runner from each guild
would travel to the maze's end. And this
process would ultimately help decide the
balance of power in Ravnica. This is all
fine and cool lore-wise, but it didn't
really get conveyed that well in the
Dragon's Maze set. The set was small and
thus felt kind of cramped with 10
guilds. And the things explicitly
mentioning parts of the lore, the gates,
the gatekeepers, and Maze's End itself
were both few and honestly pretty bad. I
didn't even know the legendary creatures
of the set were supposed to be maze
runners because the set didn't really
draw attention to this element of the
story at all. Dragon's Maze simply
didn't feel like a proper third set,
rather just a little bit of extra
Ravnica with some attached plot that not
enough effort was put into guiding us
through with its design.
The following two blocks also each
contained a set that didn't really fit
in, but in the case of those, it was the
middle set. Theros, the set, established
the plane as a setting based around
Greek myths and also introduced
characters such as Elspeth as a
monster-slaying champion and Xenagos as
a satyr planeswalker who aspired to
godhood. Born of the Gods was the second
set of the block and featured the story
of Xenagos ascending to godhood amidst
growing chaos within the pantheon.
Journey into Nyx was the third set and
focused on the consequences of Xenagos's
godhood and the ensuing showdown that
resulted from it. That all sounds fine
and good, but in terms of gameplay, the
second set, Born of the Gods, was very
strange. And a big reason why it stands
out as odd is that the other two sets
actually did a really great job
conveying the progression of the block
through their mechanics.
Theros was more focused on the mortal
plane through its heavy usage of heroic
and monstrosity as mechanics, whereas
Journey into Nyx was much more focused
around the pantheon of the gods and the
conflict within it, which could be seen
in its constellation mechanic and extra
high density of enchantments.
Born of the Gods, on the other hand,
featured a couple kind of weird
mechanics and didn't really convey a
strong sense of place or time. It felt
more like Theros B-sides than anything
else, just some kind of odd designs to
go along with a group of five gods in
order to allow the 15 gods to be evenly
spread between the three sets. It played
an undeniable role in tracing Xenagos's
storyline, but in most other ways than
that, the set was a bit of a
disappointment. The same goes to a
lesser extent for the Tarkir block.
Khans of Tarkir focused on the five
warring factions in a world where
dragons have gone extinct, and Dragons
of Tarkir features an alternate timeline
where dragons are still around, and
where Tarkir's clans and characters have
altered fates. The middle set, Fate
Reforged, was a little odd, though.
Lore-wise, it involved Sarkhan traveling
back in time to when dragons were still
around alongside the five clans and
intervening in the battle between Ugin
and Nicol Bolas. This is cool as a way
to transition between Khans and Dragons,
but in terms of gameplay, it just sort
of felt like an awkward mashup of the
two sets. Fate Reforged used three clan
keywords from Khans and two of the
changed ones from DTK. It had some
dragons rather than none or a whole
bunch, and the clans were less
three-color focused than Khans, but not
quite the two-color pairings from
Dragons.
For a middle set separated from the
other two by 1,300 years, this feels
more like the middle of an Animorphs
cover than it does its own cohesive
world.
To be clear, it is still easily the most
defensible third set of the three blocks
I've mentioned. And to be honest, I can
imagine this feeling like a genuinely
compelling three-set block with a
handful of changes to this middle set.
Nonetheless, in the format it ended up
in, Fate Reforged feels like a
continuation of a trend. One of the sets
in a block being a little awkward and
feeling more like a stepping stone for
story purposes than a fully thought-out
landscape of its own.
So, these are the two extremes. On the
one hand, you've got the current status
quo where every set is a new plane and
no setting ever has time to breathe or
experience change. And then you have the
status quo of years past where three-set
blocks are the norm and usually feature
an awkward second or third set, mostly
there for storytelling purposes.
Naturally, I would prefer that we find
our way back to a nice in-between.
Though I will say that I don't think
that in-between would be an endless
series of two-set blocks like we had in
the mid to late 2010s.
One-off sets can be great as a way to do
something funky and unusual, to explore
some bold new aesthetic territory
without committing too hard, and to have
a set where following a story isn't
necessarily a main priority.
Edge of Eternity's was a great one-off
set to shake the game up with some
out-there aesthetics and new mechanics,
and I imagine Wizards of the Coast is
enjoying the opportunity to gauge
community feedback on something like
that. The same goes for Duskmoor. I
could have taken two sets of that, but
for the player base at large, it makes
sense as an interesting experiment into
an unusual setting with a more modern
aesthetic and a way to introduce a cool
new subtype like rooms that plays into
that setting.
Even Outlaws of Thunder Junction would
have felt a lot better if it was
surrounded by a couple two-set blocks.
It's okay to have a set that's a little
silly, a little gimmicky, a little odd
story-wise. It's okay to have a hat set.
However, in order for that sort of set
to feel justified, it kind of has to
feel differentiated in some way from
what surrounds it. Has to have a degree
of adjacency to a non-hat set for the
sake of contrast, right? It might not be
clear exactly what I mean here. So, now
is as good a time as any to talk about
the specific appeals I find in two-set
blocks and why I think they should once
again become a staple part of the way
sets are structured alongside one-off
sets. The biggest reason I like two-set
blocks is that they're able to tell the
story of a place much better than a
one-set block could. Let's jump back to
the three-set blocks set on brand new
planes that I mentioned earlier, Theros
and Tarkir. Setting aside the awkward
second set in each of these, we can
notice a pattern here. Set one
establishes a setting and then a later
set complicates that setting,
introducing new elements and showcasing
a dramatically changed version of it.
This is a wonderfully blunt form of
storytelling, and seeing that clear
change communicated through the design
of a set would be great for getting
players to engage more with the lore and
ask more questions, as opposed to
one-off sets that present a snapshot of
things and then dash away at full speed.
Two-set blocks with a dramatic change
between set one and set two can also
draw out the lifespan of a given setting
without letting things feel stagnant and
without causing the negative impacts to
limited that have been caused by a lot
of blocks in the past. If both sets of a
given block are full-sized and contain
their own important features and
distinguishing characteristics, you'll
be getting the benefits of being able to
tell a story and letting players stay
engaged for longer, but you'll also get
the benefits of being able to present
each set as something cool and
different, and you can even make each
playable as its own standalone limited
format, if that's a concern. Now, all of
this still might seem a little abstract.
So, how about we talk about some
specific examples, a few sets since 2023
that might have been nice as two-set
blocks, and which to me kind of
represent missed opportunities we should
be studying.
Murders at Karlov Manor stands out as an
interesting case study because it's a
set where they were clearly going for a
version of the established-then-change
framework I mentioned earlier. Ravnica
Remastered came out in January of 2024,
followed by MKM a month later, and you
can kind of see the vision here. Remind
people what Ravnica is, and then do
something cool and different with the
Ravnica setting.
I actually think this framework could
have worked here without that many
changes to MKM itself. Instead of
Ravnica Remastered a month in advance,
drop an original new Ravnica cassette
two months in advance. In that set,
you'd want to establish the characters
and setting that would be relevant for
the following set. And importantly,
you'd want to feature the guilds. They
could maybe be a bit less present than
previous Ravnica cassettes, but they
definitely need to be there in the first
place, and they need to have some sort
of tie-in with the story of Murders at
Karlov Manor because why else are we
returning to Ravnica again? There's no
shortage of planes you could set a
murder mystery in, and choosing Ravnica
the plane about guilds with only a
feeble little "Oh yeah, this plane
exists." reprint set a month before is
just a very odd choice. So, this is one
example of a return to set that needed
an accompanying set to work well. And I
also think Lorwyn and Shadowmoor would
have been another great candidate to be
a two-set block. It's an iconic and
beloved plane, and the original Lorwyn
super block was broken up into two
separate two-set blocks, one for Lorwyn
and one for its darker counterpart
Shadowmoor.
The Lorwyn and Shadowmoor set we got was
far from bad, but it did feel a bit
rushed as a one-set return to a setting
that was originally built out with four
sets. And I have to imagine a two-set
Lorwyn plus Shadowmoor pairing would
have made for an appealing choice. So,
there are clear instances where I think
we could have benefited from a two-set
block when returning to an iconic plane.
However, to me, the biggest missed
opportunity of the past three years was
actually a new set, Bloomburrow.
I truly cannot think of a more obvious
slam dunk of a two-set block than
Bloomburrow.
Any competent market research would have
suggested that this was going to be a
very popular and well-received set, and
the final product indicates that Wizards
of the Coast was willing to put in the
necessary effort to make it great. Not
only this, but it self-justifies being a
two-set block in beautifully simple
fashion, and we can see an indication of
this in the full art lands. Imagine
this, the first set of the block is set
in late spring, and this is where we're
introduced to this vibrant world and all
its creature types. Then, the second set
of the block takes place in autumn, and
there's decidedly more urgency and
darkness as the various creatures
prepare for winter in some sense.
What exactly that looks like or how
literal versus metaphorical the
preparing for winter element is could
depend on a lot of things, but
regardless, it seems like a very natural
two-part progression. Create a setting
and then complicate it. So, if we were
still in an era where two-set blocks are
an accepted part of life, this all lines
up perfectly. A plane that feels
cohesive with the MTG universe, an
aesthetic that is almost guaranteed to
be widely appealing, and a setting that
very naturally features change over time
that can be played with in interesting
ways.
But, we're not in that sort of era. We
haven't been in an era where a new plane
could get its own block in more than
eight years. So, it didn't happen. I
vividly remember the excitement of
following the sets in a block when I was
in my first few years of playing the
game. These were localized, tangible
stories about what was happening in a
particular plane, rather than just being
one puzzle piece in a grand
meta-narrative about the omen paths or
something.
Anecdotally, when I talk to people who
started playing Magic more recently and
ask what sets they were especially
engaged with as they were getting into
the game, a frequent answer is the
four-set Phyrexia arc that concluded in
2023.
That fondness may or may not represent a
wide swath of the player base, but it's
not hard to imagine why people might be
excited about something like that. It's
a story as central to the broader Magic
lore as it gets, told over the span of
four sets with time for anticipation to
build as the Phyrexian threat ramped up.
If Bloomburrow had been a two-set block,
I have to imagine we would have had
something similar, possibly to an even
greater extent. Large swaths of players
fondly recounting their introduction
into the game being a months-long period
where Magic: The Gathering found itself
centered in a lushly realized landscape
straight out of Redwall.
In a blog post last year, Mark Rosewater
laid out his mindset on blocks in
general and Bloomburrow in specific. And
it's really interesting as a
documentation of how a major
decision-maker conceptualizes money,
people, and how the two intersect. It
starts with the objective metric that
sales are almost always lower for
subsequent sets in a block, and then
uses this data point to make a couple
strange extrapolations from there, that
players don't want to stay in the same
world for consecutive sets, and that
players respond better given a gap
between visits to a given plane.
The issue is those aren't things that
sales data can tell you. There are a ton
of reasons why subsequent sets in a
block might sell worse, and imagining
that a hypothetical second Bloomburrow
set hypothetically selling worse than
the first would have equated to players
sitting around being kind of glum about
returning to the plane too soon.
Well, it's a very odd way to
conceptualize people and what their
financial decisions mean.
And just to reiterate, I do like one-off
sets, and I genuinely understand the
benefits that Wizards of the Coast sees
in them. They allow for greater
flexibility. They allow for a higher
density of different settings, and
apparently they sell a bit better, too,
which is a genuinely understandable
consideration.
However, there can be other
considerations, because doesn't the all
one-offs status quo have a cost, too? I
mentioned earlier that I don't mind
having a hat set here or there. It's
fine to take a fun little break from
longer, more serious story arcs. But
that becomes a harder sell when every
set is a hat set, or at least when every
set receives the same treatment as a hat
set. When every set is a one-off, when
OTJ is treated the same as Bloomburrow,
which is treated the same as Spider-Man,
which is treated the same as Lorwyn,
it feels a little wrong. It feels like
the people making the game have no faith
in the world they're creating, even when
they clearly have the ability to create
something great. And, at least for me,
this disjointed mishmash of one-off sets
makes me less interested in the game,
and the clear lack of creative
conviction that this process exudes
makes me less interested in what Wizards
of the Coast has to offer as a company
that on some level produces art. I wish
we could see them being a bit more
daring, taking more risks with what
they're putting out in pursuit of
creating an excellent game.
You could argue that releasing a
never-ending string of funky one-off
sets is a version of being bold and
taking risks, but to me that's the
easier road. The harder version of being
bold is actually committing to a vision,
sincerely believing in and caring about
a product enough to see it to a
satisfying conclusion, and trusting in
your own ability to tell a multiple-part
story that people care about.
And I don't know. In 2026, I think we
could use a little more of that.
Thanks for watching, and wow, this video
ended up going a little deeper than I
intended. Why don't I make a fun little
video about blocks, I said to myself in
early March. Let me know what you think
about what I'm saying here. This is
definitely a bit outside the realm of
what I normally produce. Anyway, thanks
to Archidekt for supporting the channel.
I've been exploring some options for new
bracket formats lately, and Archidekt's
maybe board categories have been great
for keeping all my thoughts organized. A
link to my decks is down in the
description. Also, I'm going to be at
MagicCon Vegas in just a little bit, and
I'll be running a live podcast episode
on Friday alongside Tricket Mage and a
couple friends of the pod. Come on by if
that sounds up your alley.
If you want to support what I do here,
you can grab some high-quality sleeves
from Dragon Shield, affiliate link in
the description, or you can support me
more directly through Patreon or a
YouTube membership.
These folks, some of whom are on screen
now, help with the rent money, coffee,
and copies of Nexus of Becoming that
keep this channel chugging along, and
you can join them today.
Think about how accomplished you'll feel
afterward.